[Music]
hey you guys time once again for tomes
of terror my little book review show now
because this is the uh week of christmas
i decided that i was going to do a
specifically christmas themed story but
because i have some other stuff going on
and some other longer books that i need
to read like for later on in the year uh
i decided that this one was actually a
pretty perfect pick because this is not
only a christmas horror story but it is
also super short it's only a novella and
it's available for free if you have a
kindle unlimited and this is called the
visitor
by sergio gomez now sergio gomez i had
heard his name before uh on some other
uh booktuber's channels he has written a
couple of novels one of which was called
camp slaughter i feel like that one got
reviewed a lot and he also wrote one
called the toy maker which i is it why a
i kind of feel like i don't know why i'm
thinking that but
it might be y a but uh yeah so both of
those have been like pretty widely
reviewed he's also done a couple of
short story collections so you know he's
kind of uh you know been around now this
was uh the first
uh thing of his that i had read now as i
said this is
very very short uh it's about 70 pages i
think i read it in an hour
so
you know so if just if you just want
something kind of like fun and breezy
and quick
to read that's kind of like a christmas
horror story you could certainly uh do
worse than this
it came out last year like december of
2020 and what the setup is and honestly
like
this would be kind of hard to spoil in
the sense that it's a very
straightforward kind of story and the
cover of it the cover of it i love by
the way i just love the cover of this uh
if you look at the um title card of this
video you'll see what the cover looks
like but i really really like it so the
cover pretty much spoils that this is a
this is an alien story so it's i'm not
spoiling that because it's right there
on the cover there's a little alien
stand in front of a christmas tree so
what you have is uh this is basically
set in kind of a
rural or remote part of indiana uh on
christmas
eve uh christmas eve or christmas day it
doesn't really matter
uh at night and it's one it's in the
middle of like the worst snowstorm to
have hit indiana in however long so what
ends up happening is that there's this
little diner like out off the highway
and in this diner there's a dude named
sal who is presumably the owner and he's
also the cook uh he says something early
on about oh he has a couple waitresses
that work there too but he gave them the
night off because it was christmas uh so
you know he's a good guy like that so
you have sal it's his diner
and then there's a guy that's already in
there like uh eating something his name
is moshi and he's uh like an author poet
comedian uh he's been in town doing a
book signing or something like that
uh and then also in the diner there's a
japanese couple
uh kato and ichiko
who live around there they live like
half a mile away like in this kind of
remote cabin and apparently they do
these kind of uh they they have a
tradition where they go out and hike in
the mountains and then when they come
back from the hike they go to this diner
and have some fried mushrooms or
whatever so so they're kind of like
regulars at the diner and they're kind
of always there
now uh so those people are already in
the diner
and then you're following a couple of
other characters uh there's a guy named
xavier and he has a border collie named
norman
and they're on their way they're i guess
they're going to somebody's house for
christmas like there's his sister's
house or something like that i can't
remember but he was going somewhere for
christmas or to see his parents or
something and uh they end up like the
visibility is getting really bad like
the storm is getting really bad and he's
out on the highway and his car ends up
hitting this weird like metal thing in
the road that looks like you know part
of another car that was an earlier
accident uh the tires pop the car spins
out and it hits a guard rail and [ __ ]
the car all up so he's kind of stuck
so him and his dog kind of get out of
the car there's no cell phone service so
he can't call triple a
so he's kind of hosed he's not really
sure what he's going to do
and but it so happens that just a little
way down the road uh there's a guy named
santiago who is a truck driver and he's
been driving his big rig but he had to
pull it over because visibility was so
bad and he happened to see the car crash
so he comes over to see if he can help
but because the car is kind of messed up
and no one's going anywhere because of
the storm they're like well there's a
diner not too far over there so let's go
over there and see what we can see go
get something to eat or cup of coffee
and wait the storm out
so they all go over to the diner and
everybody's in the diner now
so this is basically one of those kind
of like one location everyone's kind of
trapped in this diner uh and then like
bad [ __ ] starts to happen so there's
kind of like a brief period where
everyone
kind of gets to know each other you know
they're just like talking shooting the
[ __ ] or whatever they kind of do a
little bit of establishing backstory
about like santiago was trying
desperately to finish up his runs so he
could get home to see his wife and kids
uh you know for christmas and all this
other stuff and he's kind of bummed out
he's not gonna be able to do it now he's
missed his wife's last phone call and
all this other stuff
so they all end up in this diner
now after a few minutes uh the power
winks out and sal uh the owner of the
diner says okay well i'm gonna go down
to the basement and figure out like what
is going on you know the fuse box or
whatever yeah this is a horror story
don't ever go down in the basement or up
in the attic you know perhaps don't ever
check out that noise it never ends well
and indeed it does not end well in this
situation either uh because sal goes
down there and a couple seconds later
they hear him screaming so a couple of
them go down there to investigate uh
what has happened to him
now from there
what ensues is basically just
a chase or like a fight for survival
type of thing
with uh an alien being and the alien
beings i guess it's kind of like a
hunting dog they don't know that at
first because it's just like looks like
a monster but then you find out later on
that that's essentially like that aliens
like hunting dog
and the alien has apparently come to the
earth
to
collect human organs
i'm not entirely sure what they're gonna
do with them
but that's why he's there like he just
comes and kills humans takes their
organs and puts them in a little case or
a little suitcase and he's gonna take
him back to his home planet
so that's pretty much how the story goes
um you know at some point like a bunch
of people get killed and uh you know a
couple of them have to run out into the
snow they're trying to get to the
japanese couple's cabin which is like
half a mile away like in the snow is
just horrible and then like the aliens
chasing them and then the alien has like
you know uh alien rifle alien technology
and all this other kind of stuff so you
know they're so they're trying to like
get away from the alien they see the
ship and all this other stuff so um as i
said this is if you want something
that's just kind of like fun and not you
can just kind of turn your brain off and
just read it and it's kind of
christmassy you know and it's aliens
which is kind of cool it's not
i'm not usually like real into like
alien kind of stuff but this was
actually pretty fun
um one thing i will say you know if i'm
going to rate it
uh and i haven't read sergio gomez's
other stuff um i did hear some good
stuff about camp slaughter
so i might get into that at some point
too because i remember seeing some other
reviews of that and them being good
this one um it's a good story it's like
a fun concept uh very simple it's very
violent pretty gory um you know pretty
much everybody gets killed a spoiler
alert uh in horrible ways and uh so
that's kind of cool because you know
like nobody's safe and that kind of [ __ ]
so it does have some like really good
kind of chase scenes where like the
alien's trying to get him they're like
out in the snow and they're hiding
behind the trees and [ __ ] like that
but
i think that this would have benefited
from a couple of things
uh one i think it needed to be this is a
self-published author and i'm not
[ __ ] on that because i'm also a
self-published author to a large degree
and uh you know so and it's tough out
there because there's a lot of
competition
uh but i think in this case uh maybe
um a professional editor would have
helped because there are some
grammatical errors um and there are some
you know punctuation errors uh there are
some things where you know some stuff is
kind of like not clear or one word is
used like a whole bunch of times when
they could have like mixed it up so
this definitely needed to be
edited because like i said the hot the
the concept is good um the story is good
the writing is okay but it just really
seemed like some of the grammar was kind
of wonky also the dialogue was a little
bit uh
weird or like stilted
and i was watching another review of
this and she pointed out too that um a
lot of the characters dialogue because
you know the six or seven different
characters um their dialogue they they
all sound alike so they they didn't
really have distinctive voices
and i think that was kind of more
that was kind of more um because
this really needed because i really
liked this idea like i really liked the
setup i really liked the idea of them
being chased you know through the snow
with by this alien
i really kind of wish that this was
longer i really wish that this was like
a whole
novel instead of just a novella because
you know it's only 70 pages long so i
feel like
there wasn't really enough time
for all of these characters to
be developed to a point where you'd be
like ah you'd be bummed out like when
they died you know what i mean because
it just seemed like everything just went
by too quick um the characters were
introduced very quickly xavier kind of
had a little bit of a thing because you
actually got to see him get in the car
accident and like react to that santiago
was built up a little bit because you
know you got into his head a little bit
but most of the other characters you
didn't really learn anything about them
um you know what their backstory was
like why they were at this diner you
know you didn't so so there wasn't like
enough time for because i don't know
there just wasn't enough time for you to
like for all these characters to be
established and to have their own
individuality and stuff like that they
all seemed
you know it they all seem to just have
been like put here in this diner to be
like alien fodder pretty much and like i
said i think that that's that's more
that's more because it was just a very
short story and maybe if all of these
characters getting picked off one by one
by the alien you could have totally
expanded that to like novel length and
i'm not saying that you had to do like a
dissertation
on every single character like what
their backstory was to like you know to
try to make people care about them you
don't have to do that i mean
characterization
is difficult to do but i mean it can be
done
briefly economically you don't have to
write a [ __ ] novel about each
person's situation
there's just like a few little things
that will kind of make people relate to
them and make them stand out as a
character more so i do kind of wish that
that had been done a little bit and i
think that would probably be my main
criticism of it is that it just it was
too short i mean it's just too short um
you couldn't really get into and and
there wasn't really a lot of explanation
about the alien like the alien
the his hunting dog was actually kind of
cool the way he described him it kind of
reminded me a little bit of the
demigorgon you know from stranger things
so it was kind of like that kind of
thing where it was kind of like cat-like
but then it had like
reptilian like alligator kind of skin
and like its mouth open sideways and so
it kind of reminded me of that type of
thing um but the alien
sounded just kind of like your standard
alien like with big eyes and gray skin
and he had like a you know like a
spacesuit like a black suit and a you
know a thing a helmet or whatever yeah
and like i said they didn't really give
a backstory to like the aliens there
were like some hints that
obviously the alien had come from
a ship because there was a thing where
you know some
somebody kept hearing like alien talking
like over phones or like over the radio
or whatever uh so there were so there
were other aliens in the area like the
ship so they were obviously doing like a
mission where they were you know coming
and collecting human organs but it would
have kind of been cool to like find out
why they were doing that or where they
came from or something so as i said this
is a totally fun just christmas alien if
you like alien horror you might be into
it um it's just like a really fun breezy
read it took me about an hour maybe not
even that long
to read and it just goes by really quick
uh it's just very action-packed pretty
gory um i just would have liked to see
one uh it edited because some of the
grammar was uh was not good but you know
and there were just mistakes in there
that shouldn't
have been in there some people said oh
it read like a first draft it kind of
did um i don't i don't know if i'd go
quite that far but i get what they're
saying
um so yeah so it could have been cleaned
up some but i think it could have been
fleshed out expanded
and it would have been a lot better
because there's a lot of directions you
could go with that you could go way into
the backstories of the characters you
could go into the backstory of the alien
and like why are they here and what are
they doing you know so there's like
really cool concepts here that i just
wish had been expanded upon and that's
it but that said uh it's still like
pretty fun if you just want something to
read real quick on christmas that'll
maybe put you in the christmas kind of
mood and you like aliens uh then you
know you could totally you'd probably
like enjoy it and if you have kindle
unlimited then you can read it on there
for free so you know go check it out and
uh see what you think of it and tell me
if you agree with me if you don't agree
with me uh and we'll have a discussion
about it in the comments and that will
do it for this tomes of terror i will
see you guys on the next one
bye